I don't like new positive Dan.
Man, alright. Let's just ...
Me and Shane don't like it.
Ooh, you're new boyfriend!
He's single, white femaling me.
I'm just saying, you know,
he came over to watch the game.
We shared some depressing times
together. Some good food.
Is this 'cause
he's an Eagles fan?
I won't be an Eagles fan.
Laughs. I wasn't done
explaining our night.
Sweet dessert treats.
That's great.
Some high fives were involved.
Wings! He loves wings.
This is the most petty...
I like petty Jay.
It's hit's favorite food, wings.
Yeah. Petty Jay.
Wow.
You went on the offense there
when I was getting
ready to say ...
No, hell yeah,
I went on the offense.
There's not a radio slut
in this world that could take
the place of my Danny Soder.
That's what I was gonna say!
I don't care, I'm already out.
While you were uncorking on me.
I'm already packed up.
Being scorned
by my radio husband.
For a man that I brought around.
I basically ...
You're not scorned.
I honestly got ...
This is like when
a rich guy hires,
when like the wife is like,
"We need a nanny.
Get an au pair."
And then this Brazilian girl
comes in and the husbands like,
"I'm gonna marry the au pair.
You're out of here."
And she's like ...
That's what I am!
Shane and me both think
you'd look really good
on a long board.
Dude, I'm so uncoordinated
that a long board
would result in my death.
I've never put two feet
on a skateboard in my life.
It's never happened one time.
Not once?
Not one time ever!
Should we do a ...
Here's what I do
I put my foot ...
Should we do a Bonfire X Games?
We ride skateboards?
Dude ...
For the heart of shame?
If I could get on one
I'd be impressed with myself.
I've always put
one foot on it.
Yeah.
I roll it back and forth
a couple times. I go, no way.
Really?
I've done that a hundred times
in my life.
I'm like a baby deer.
I can't skate at all.
When I see a guy run and jump
onto a skateboard
and start skating I go,
you might as well ...
Suck your own ass.
That guy could probably
do brain surgery.
Yeah. He could probably do
a standing back flip.
Yeah. No doubt.
Yeah. You know what's weird,
when you see...
But I also believe
standing back flip,
again, if I believed in myself,
I could achieve that.
You know ...
Much like a kid,
if I just believed
I could accomplish it ...
Yeah.
And saw the follow
through in my head,
the same way I told him here
where I did Comedy Jam
in Phoenix
when I was gonna get on
the front of the bar to sing.
Yeah.
And it was like a bar
that I definitely could've
pushed myself up
and planted my foot.
But all I saw in my head
going up for it,
I was just like,
I'm gonna miss it,
end up throwing my knee
up there last minute nervous,
and then have to roll
onto a bar.
And you can't be a fat guy
rolling onto a bar
to go sing a song.
That's what they kick
fat people out of bars for.
When we, I went and saw St.
Paul and The Broken Bones
with Ari Shaffir and Greg
Fucking hipster brag.
Yeah, it's real hipster
brag sure.
But the guy got stuck
on the amp crawling up,
he's like kind of a chubby dude
in like a leopard print suit,
and he like "aah",
and he's singing
and he goes "Aah",
and just stayed
where he was at.
Scott, I'm actually
gonna need a little help.
Aah. Yeah.
Seriously guys, my knees
caught in a funny way.
"Aah."
And I was like, dude,
this guy's not getting down.
And he's just singing.
And this is his voice (singing),
And he's just on this amp.
"Oh shit!"
Stuck.
Yeah, it was great.
I love it. Just stuck.
And you watch him after
the song be like, okay, alright
and then just
slowly back down.
Dude, my first
Marilyn Manson concert
ever, he came out
on the stilts.
He has this thing
where he comes out with stilts
and big crutch handles.
Yeah.
And he's got a helmet on.
Like a weird leathery helmet
with a microphone
attached to it.
And he's coming up
to sing this song ...
That does sounds also like
very 1800's circusy.
Oh you can find videos
of the stilts.
Just 'cause helmet with stilts.
Yeah. It's supposed
to look bizarre.
And ...
The world's tallest man!
And he usually sings.
The mic just wasn't working.
And watching him
try at one point ...
watching someone scream rock
when you can't hear a word
they're saying.
You just see like,
wide open mouths.
Can I ask the question of,
if we don't have video of it,
was he walking around on the
stilts in like an evil way?
Yes.
Was he trying to do a creepy ...
'Cause that takes ...
you have to be in character ...
And the mic wasn't working.
So when you have a technical
failure your like,
"I'm coming ...
oh god damn it, guys!
I'm coming for your soul
and I'm coming ... ah man!"
So what he does is he just
ends up going like even funnier.
He gets angry.
He realizes it's not working.
Yeah.
And he throws
the crutch handles away.
Mm-hmm.
And watching somebody huff off
in three foot high stilts
is one of the funniest ...
'cause he throws the things,
you see he's yelling
at somebody offstage,
and then has to go (singing)
Ah dude!
Like an old Uncle Sam.
"Hey everybody!"
I bet it does blunt the blow
to watch the person
that's about to yell at you
walk over in cirus fashion.
Yeah.
Where you're like, I'm about to
get yelled at by a guy on stilts
so this won't be as bad
as if he was grounded.
Yeah. Guys sorry,
quick little technical issue.
I have to go back stage.
Just a stilt walk.
Everyone just enjoy this balloon
animal twister
while I go over here and get
this technical problem handled.
Sometimes evil doesn't work
with it's microphone.
Sometimes people, the circus
brings you live entertainment
that goes awry.
If we could just take
a quick intermission right now,
watch this bear
running on a ball!
Back when the circus
meant something!
Yeah, that's right,
animal rights' activists!
Before we cared about elephants.
Before we started thinking
about how elephants take it.
Stupid ass elephants.
How many people do elephants
kill a year Christine?
Let's get those numbers!
No one's talking
about those numbers!
You gotta ... it's funny
to think like, a subject
that no one's been provocative
about, but you're like,
I'm gonna be provocative
about that.
Like, bring back the circus.
And they're like,
why is this your
hill to die on?
Because I miss it.
Because the circus use
to do cool shit.
I want an excuse to wear
a glow necklace.
Yeah, oh man.
There'd be so many animal
rights' activists
that be like, this is the enemy
we've always wanted.
Hell yeah.
This is the guy ...
Let's do it.
Bring back the circus.
The Bonfire circus.
The Bonfire ...
hashtag bring back the circus.
Where's the circus?
Everyone likes the circus!
Extra animal cruelty!
I don't want no more accidents!
I'm talking about ...
let's go Roman.
You fucking whip these animals
into shape.
Whatever it takes!
Let's go Roman.
Humans versus animals.
Let's make it count
for something.
Bring back the circus.
Lions fight prisoners.
And Catholics.
Specifically Catholics.
Catholic prisoners.
We go weird, odd one thing.
Oh man.
We lure them in the fighting
religion in prison,
and then we feed them
to lions.
Shout out to Marilyn Manson
for sponsoring us.
He's going to be
our dark overlord.
Do walking off ...
do you have a picture
of him on those stilts?
There's probably
a video of it going,
but I assume it was the first
and only time it ever happened.
What that he had
technical issues on ...
Stilts.
Stilts
Yeah.
'Cause stilt walking is
such a ridiculous thing ...
Yeah but without the stilts
doing like the creepy
spider thing,
and you just angrily ...
it's just a clunky ...
Yeah, you have to clunk off.
Yeah, 'cause here he's like,
"I'll kill you and ..."
Oh, look at it.
It looks fun!
Yeah with the crutch handles
it looks super fun!
Can you imagine just coming out
and just scaring someone?
Just coming around the corner
like,
if you could move
on that fucking thing!
Answer your door with it.
Yeah.
And ...
And then you go,
"Oh, I'll just take that."
Holy shit!
Why do you have that!
You go, "hey!"
Soders moving like
a giant spider!
I don't like it!
What's up guys? I'm here
for the fantasy football draft.
"Hey guys. Table for two."
Walk through and come down.
"Do you guys have two?
High tops would be preferable."
Two tickets for The Hate
You Give. We'll take the stairs.
Oh, no need. Just trying to be
on an escalator
all fucking tight
in those things.
But you can even picture
watching this.
He throws those crutches away,
he looks like a doofus.
Yeah. Evil rock and roll
goes corny real quick.
Yeah. As soon as you
get back stage
and went into a brightly
lit dressing room.
Yeah. And you like ...
And you're just sweaty
and covered in makeup.
Yeah, that's why
I was always ...
And you have to go,
"Isaac, can you get me a towel?"
That's where our age difference
is,
it's because like Motley Cru
and the hair rock
and like the glam metal
of the 80's to me was ridiculous
'cause I was young enough
that it was over
by the time
I was into music.
Yeah.
So I was like, oh these guys
are just wearing makeup?
But they're like,
it was so cool at the time.
And I'm like, okay.
It was just cool in like,
a place.
Because no one
in my neighborhood
at that time went ...
Here's what they would do,
the goofy hair for sure.
Yeah.
A half top tank top.
Great.
Without a doubt.
That's what I think
we should bring back.
But no one went full blown like,
makeup and
Glam metal.
It's a shame dude.
Yeah.
"Look What the Cat Dragged In"?
Killer tune.
Got some good fucking tunes
those hair bands,
but man it was such a ...
But do you know what I'm saying?
Like it's ...
Such a genre of music.
It's always funny to me
that also the satanic rock,
when you look back at it,
you're like, this isn't scary.
Like Guar maybe holds up.
It's like, well, that's pretty
fucking terrifying and weird,
but when you see
Marilyn Manson ...
like teenagers now wouldn't be
like, oh that guy's evil.
They'd be like ...
Oh, Marilyn Manson
being dangerous now?
Yeah.
It's like, no.
Yeah, that's what I mean.
You know what I mean?
If you say that fat neck guy
who fucked Juice
on Son's of Anarchy?
And you'd be right.
Yeah. But like Ozzy!
Ozzy's like another one
where in the '70s there like,
he bit heads of bats.
He was just crazy.
And now he's like ...
Oh, forget even that.
How about when he went and ...
In hair metal
you gotta remember,
Ozzy was famous
through hair metal.
Yeah!
So ...
I mean, Ozzy's a legend.
So Ozzy went ...
But I'm saying, the whole evil
thing ...
Ozzy went hair metal at a point.
No, I'm saying
he dropped evil quick ...
The way that Kiss went disco?
And went ...
Dude, bring up the Shot
in The Dark video of Ozzy.
Its' the the funniest ...
It'll make you be like, was
this guy really looked at ...
Yeah.
Like that dangerous?
Well you know what's ...
as a wrestling fan,
Hogan Knows Best
like completely ruined
Hulk-a-mania because I was ...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just see him get yelled
at by his wife.
And she's like, "Terry,
you didn't do this right!"
And you're like,
Hulks kicked out of the ...
That takes that away too,
and I get what you're saying
about Ozzy seeing him
on The Osborne Show.
That's what I mean!
It's killed ... you just have
to enjoy his music
because before that,
watching a guy be evil ...
Yeah.
Being glam evil ...
Glam evil, glam evil's ...
Is one of the gayest
things ever.
Yeah.
I mean with teased
Chip and Dale's hair.
Is this the video?
We're just going through
some technical issues.
Listen guys, here at
The Bonfire, we're human.
We have technical issues,
we start late sometimes because
it doesn't work.
That's what happens.
Sometimes our Ozzy videos
don't load properly,
but you can change this
by Go Funding my ...
Bring back the circus.
Jimmy, bring back the circus
and Dan Soder's Jimmy G tour.
I leave the show, Shane comes
in.
Potato, potato.
I'm following that
handsome son of a bitch,
racking up
W's next season.
You're gonna be his motivator?
His personal motivator?
Yeah. In a poncho.
It'll all come together.
Oh, what's wrong?
We can't watch the video?
I'm not getting an official
for Shot In The Dark.
Really?
There's live performances ...
That upsets me.
It's such a ridiculous video.
Try to find it on something.
Yeah.
It's a ridiculous video.
But Marilyn Manson never went,
he didn't change.
You know? Like I was trying
to think what would be the ...
What?
But I'm saying Marilyn Manson,
what did he change to?
He went that ...
he did all the goth shit.
Yeah.
It was like the goth
Willy Wonka shit.
Then it was the goth,
more like Nine Inch Nails,
leather straps and evil ...
Oh.
No, but then the next album
he went like glam rock.
Like The Dope Show
and all that shit.
like completely changed.
Really?
Yeah, he followed David
Bowie's trajectory in like,
you know a much
less accessible way.
I'm not gonna lie,
I did not know
Marilyn Manson went that deep.
You don't remember that whole,
when he wore the tits
on the album cover?
That when I was like,
being introduced to him.
Like, by the time I caught
wind of Marilyn Manson ...
But you've seen ...
Yeah.
Before that it was all like the
gothic and ...
I saw all that, but ...
And then he went back
to the goth thing.
To me that was like, oh yeah,
that's Marilyn Manson.
Yeah.
That's how I learned
about Marilyn Manson.
Yeah but that whole thing ...
It was Mechanical Animals.
When you see him
when he's young,
I mean, he's just a goofy,
skinny, ugly kid
with straggly long hair.
Yeah.
And then he became
a beautiful piece of art.
Yeah.
And I mean that,
but I have to say it like
I'm just joking when I say it.
Yeah, but you really do.
I really do.
You hold on to that.
You go, "aah,
I really do love you."
You beautiful piece of art.
I should have fucking had the
cheek of dick when I said that.
Yeah, hold on. Or just stroke
one out of your mouth.
You're like, "aah,
beautiful piece of art."
He became a beautiful
piece of art.
The second picture down
in the second row,
the second to the left.
Yeah, him having a regular
conversation
outside of a brick wall in
that outfit is pure buffoonery.
He looks like a hooker
pushed to the point.
You know what, I'm just gonna
go back and sell Cut Co.
Knives for the summer
and then I'm gonna go
back to beauty school.
Yeah, the Johns like it
when I dress a little weird.
They like to call me,
they call me Mad Max.
A lot of people don't know is
that I could take out
six of my front teeth.
I'm like a snake.
I can unbuckle.
Oh, the video does not exist?
That's why everywhere
I'm finding it on weird sites,
when you play it it says
the video doesn't exist.
Did Sharon Osborne flex
that fucking disappearing power?
Oh, no.
Was she like, "I want it gone,
and I want it gone yesterday!"
Ask why you can't find
the Shot in The Dark video.
'Cause Ozzy knows
what's out there.
"Sharon, before I die,
Clean all of my glam?
please take down
the Shot In The Dark video."
"I didn't know
what I was doing."
I like all of his glam.
He wants his glam submerged.
I didn't know he went glam.
I mean ...
This is the song.
This is his hair rock for sure.
That video ...
You like this song?
This is not my favorite
Ozzy song
but I probably because the video
he looks so stupid that I ....
You remember it?
Oh, yeah! It's burned in my ...
He's wearing like
a Liberace wizard cape.
Bing it! Go to Bing!
Jacob how ...
You can get a still of
just his hair poofed out.
And his hair ...
I'm finding ...
I'm still searching.
He's got Swasey Chip
and Dale's hair.
Oh man. By the way ...
He looks like an idiot!
Can I just say the first time
like, this is the first time I
felt like
this radio show is like a
submarine.
'Cause I'm like, "Christine,
you can just Bing it."
She's like,
"I'm trying everything I got.
I'm getting nothing on this."
He goes, the powers out.
The whole thing. I dunno.
Our backup generators
all fucked up.
The whole grids blown.
I don't know what's going on.
Yeah, there's a link
on VH1 Classics,
but then the videos
not actually there.
It's not a classic?
I thought it was a classic.
VH1 doesn't think
it's a classic?
What if I told you the video
was never filmed?
Did you Bing it?
Yeah.
Type in the word
'tit fuck' also.
Oh dude, should we take a break
and then come back
for that clip?
We gotta start with that clip.
Let's also see in the break
if we can find this Ozzy
Osbourne video because it's
worth putting it out there.
I mean, he looks ridiculous.
Yeah, I wanna see it.
Is this ...
would this be the video here?
Yes! That would be
the video for sure.
Why did they have it scrubbed?
I always find it interesting
when shit's scrubbed
from the internet ...
Chris Rock's first pitch
and this.
That's what been scrubbed.
And now my favorite worst
comic ever video from YouTube.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your favorite bomb.
I know, it was my favorite.
But whatever. No one cares.
Shot in the dark.
Shane already made me feel
pretty good about it.
What did you just say?
What? I didn't say
anything dude.
I love you so much.
Let's take a break.
It's "The Bonfire."
Poncho dance coming.